Traduttore: Elena Montrasio
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Quanto preoccupati siete,
personalmente, del cambiamento climatico?
In una scala da 1 a 10,
quanto preoccupati siete
del cambiamento climatico
e del riscaldamento globale?
Uno, poco; dieci, tantissimo.
Bene.
Tranne a TED, si parla relativamente poco
del cambiamento climatico.
Se pensate ai media, se ne parla poco
in paragone, diciamo,
a quanto si parla di Trump,
a quanto si parla della Brexit,
o della riforma costituzionale.
Sui social media,
se non avete degli amici
veramente appassionati dal tema,
anche lì è raro, in fondo,
che le notizie appaiano.
Ma quello che è più sorprendente
è quanto poco se ne parli
a casa, con gli amici, a un tavolo.
Degli studi, in America,
del Climate Change Communication,
nel centro di Yale,
mostrano che il 70 percento
degli americani
non hanno mai, o molto raramente,
parlato di cambiamento climatico
nel loro cerchio prossimo di amici.
Questo è particolarmente
sorprendente perché;
adesso non so i vostri risultati,
ma negli ultimi anni è molto chiaro
che il livello di consapevolezza
rispetto ai cambiamenti è molto elevato -
siamo all'80 percento
nella maggior parte dei paesi -
e quello che sta crescendo,
anche, molto rapidamente
è il livello di preoccupazione.
Posso immaginare che, probabilmente,
una buona parte di voi avrà messo
qualcosa tra il sei e il dieci,
a livello di preoccupazione.
Allora perché non se ne parla?
Perché se ne parla poco, malgrado
questo livello di ansia, in fondo?
Un grande scrittore, Amitav Gosh, dice:
È un po' come parlare della morte,
si cerca di non parlarne.
Altri, degli psicologi -
ci sono tanti psicologi, adesso,
che si stanno occupando
di cercare di capire
la nostra relazione con l'ambiente -
dicono che abbiamo proprio un problema
a riconoscere negli altri
questo livello di interesse
e di preoccupazione.
Evitiamo, finiamo in una specie
di spirale del silenzio,
perché in fondo pensiamo
che agli altri non interessi,
e dunque evitiamo di parlare di cose
che rischiano di metterci in conflitto,
o rischiano di imbarazzarci.
Ecco, quando però si cade;
se a livello del discorso personale
questo non emerge,
questo tarlo di preoccupazione rimane.
E se cambiamo il livello di analisi,
se iniziamo a guardare
ai comportamenti, alle pratiche quotidiane
e a me piace guardare
quello che le persone
fanno nel quotidiano,
vediamo che i cambiamenti
sono molto, molto superiori.
Abbiamo fatto un paio di studi:
il primo è uno studio
abbastanza divertente,
che abbiamo fatto a Milano
in occasione del Salone del Mobile.
Visto che c'è un grande passaggio,
abbiamo messo due grandi lavagne
con due frasi un po' provocatorie:
"Per fermare il cambiamento climatico,
io _____", e poi c'è da completare.
O: "Stiamo uccidendo il pianeta,
ma non riesco a non ___".
Dunque, visto il flusso che c'è -
questo era alla Cascina Cuccagna -
visto il flusso di gente abbiamo avuto
centinaia e centinaia di risposte,
tanto che ogni tot ore
dovevamo cancellare tutto dalla lavagna.
Quello che è interessante,
e che parla un pochino a questo fenomeno
del silenzio progressivo,
era che le lavagne si riempivano di più
quando c'erano già delle cose,
cioè il primo riflesso
era quello di andare a guardare:
"Lasciatemi andare vicino,
lasciateci guardare
cosa gli altri hanno scritto,
vedere cosa altre persone facevano"
e poi completavano.
E ci sono dei pattern,
e quello che è veramente interessante
è che son saltate fuori
centinaia di piccole soluzioni,
piccole pratiche quotidiane.
Tante intorno alla mobilità,
tante persone che parlano
della bicicletta, ecc.,
tante persone, ovviamente,
intorno al cibo,
poi delle cose divertenti,
non ho la vasca ecc.
In Italia
quello che emerge molto chiaramente
è una grande attenzione all'acqua,
l'acqua come risorsa preziosa:
tengo l'acqua, lavo di meno,
cerco di farmi delle docce corte, ecc.
Dunque dei temi ricorrenti,
poi tante soluzioni individuali.
Era un pochino una provocazione,
ma era anche il momento
di far partire delle discussioni
che abbiamo avuto,
in modo abbastanza approfondito.
Ecco, un altro studio invece
che abbiamo fatto a Londra,
questo più di natura etnografica
che è quello che io faccio in genere.
Siamo andati a vedere, di nuovo,
come si svolge il quotidiano,
qual è la vita quotidiana,
e come le pratiche quotidiane
sono, in un certo senso,
informate o no, o influenzate o no,
da una certa consapevolezza
del cambiamento della propria azione
sul cambiamento del clima.
Allora, due parole di premessa
sulla vita londinese:
sicuramente [lo] sapete anche voi,
un costo della vita allucinante;
un costo delle abitazioni pazzesco;
una crisi molto forte,
dunque, dell'abitazione.
Per cui, una grande
proporzione di persone,
soprattutto prima del periodo
della famiglia, ecc.
che vivono in spazi condivisi:
ci si affitta un appartamento insieme.
Questo è il punto di partenza:
che è visto anche, però,
non solo come una soluzione economica
ma anche [come] una soluzione sociale.
E anche, in fondo, a un primo passo
verso una specie
di condivisione delle risorse.
Ecco, quando si parla di mobilità,
nessuna delle persone
con cui abbiamo discusso,
e che abbiamo osservato in casa,
possiede un'automobile personale.
Tanti non hanno neanche la patente,
dunque il mezzo
di trasporto per eccellenza
è, naturalmente, a piedi
e i trasporti in comune.
E poi la bicicletta, di nuovo,
visto i costi esorbitanti
dei trasporti londinesi.
La scelta della bicicletta
nasce, fondamentalmente,
per quattro motivazioni forti,
che sono un po' il tema che, vedremo,
attraversa un pochino tutte le scelte.
Uno è quello dell'ambiente;
il secondo, chiaramente, quello del costo;
il terzo, molto importante,
quello della salute,
cioè il fatto di fare esercizio,
di muoversi, eccetera;
e il quarto è quello
di una certa autonomia, il controllo,
di un senso di controllo
sui propri spostamenti.
Il secondo punto dove stiamo vedendo
una trasformazione molto grossa
è intorno all'alimentazione.
Un po' come abbiamo visto in Italia:
una crescita importante
delle persone che non mangiano carne;
e poi una crescita di quelli
che vengono chiamati flexitarian,
persone che hanno ridotto
in modo drastico la carne,
però non sono dogmatici:
Se capita, non sono così [rigidi].
E poi una tensione, veramente pronunciata,
all'origine del cibo:
il fatto che non venga
da troppo lontano,
che non venga dalla Nuova Zelanda.
Una specie di attenzione.
E anche lì, quando possibile,
cibo organico.
Dunque, anche lì quattro fattori.
Cioè questo fattore di controllo,
di maggiore consapevolezza
su quello che è la salute,
il costo e l'ambiente,
è molto, molto forte.
Una cosa che sta succedendo
a Londra, molto interessante,
che era scomparsa,
una cosa un po' per persone anziane,
sono gli allotment, gli orti condivisi.
Ci sono 25 anni di attesa,
nella maggior parte dei borough,
per avere accesso a un orto.
Abbiamo incontrato
un po' di persone che lo fanno
e se non riescono fanno crescere
cose varie sui loro terrazzi.
Anche lì, qual è il tema?
È quello del: voglio provare
cosa vuol dire far crescere qualcosa.
Voglio tentare, ma tentare che cosa?
Tentare che cosa comporta?
Una specie di spirito di conoscenza.
I consumi: ecco, forse anche lì
c'è un cambiamento veramente radicale.
Il motto, la parola chiave,
è sempre stata: poco, ma di qualità.
La lotta contro la quantità
a bassissimo costo,
il "lo lavo due volte poi lo butto
perché di pessima qualità".
Tutti ci dicono: poco, ma di qualità.
Qui ci ritroviamo, anche,
con il fatto di avere spazi condivisi,
per cui la possibilità
di un accumulo è molto inferiore,
e il fatto di muoversi in bicicletta,
per cui non poter trasportare
da lontano, ecc.
Però c'è una coscienza molto forte.
Abbiamo sentito tante volte la frase:
"Tutto è energia, noi mangiamo CO2,
tutto quello che abbiamo
è prodotto con energia".
Dunque una fortissima coscienza.
E qui vorrei fare una micro parentesi,
perché c'è un discorso molto forte,
da parte degli economisti,
che tutte le nostre scelte
e tutti i cambiamenti di consumi
sono essenzialmente dovute alla crisi.
Qui, quello che abbiamo osservato
è veramente una posizione morale,
una posizione rispetto a un cambiamento
del modo di consumare profondo.
Poi un'altra cosa,
sempre nei consumi, l'idea del ciclo.
Quello che interessa, in un certo senso,
è avere delle cose
che possano non solo durare,
ma che possano essere riparate,
che possano essere passate avanti.
Una cosa che sta funzionando
moltissimo, a Londra,
sono questi servizi di freecycling:
ho un tavolo, cambio casa,
metto on line il fatto
che questo tavolo è disponibile,
qualcuno passa a prenderlo, lo do via,
io stesso cambio casa,
cerco un tavolo,
vedo on line che cosa c'è .
Una specie di ciclo
molto più lungo del consumo.
Un tema molto forte,
nel quale la sensazione di autonomia,
invece, non è presente
è quello dell'energia.
Tante persone,
per le loro condizioni di vita,
per il fatto di condividere,
di essere in condomini, dicono:
"Ci piacerebbe cambiare
le nostre fonti di energia,
ma non possiamo.
Siamo un pochino succubi su questo".
Ma è un tema che è presente.
O fare delle cose di questo genere,
e collegarsi a un impianto fotovoltaico,
oppure cambiare.
Ecco: quali sono le tematiche,
le parole chiavi che abbiamo sentito?
Chiaramente, c'è una parola molto forte,
che è quella di precarietà.
Che non è solo la precarietà economica,
ma proprio una specie
di precarietà assoluta,
cioè precarietà dell'ambiente,
precarietàdi esistenza, ecc.
E a questa si oppone, molto fortemente,
l'idea di un tentativo di recuperare
la propria, in inglese, agency,
il proprio controllo,
la propria possibilitàdi azione.
E tanti di questi modi
sono volti a recuperare,
in un certo senso, l'azione.
Poi abbiamo sentito, tante volte,
la parola "risorse" e "responsabilità".
Due cose che vanno insieme:
cosa posso fare?
Scelgo una risorsa
su cui sono responsabile.
Però, quello che è molto forte
è il fatto che tutte queste dinamiche -
tutti ci hanno parlato del fatto
di quanto siano personali, queste azioni,
quanto in fondo siano individuali.
Come dicevo, non c'è un discorso pubblico.
Per cui la gente
si sente relativamente sola,
in queste piccole azioni
che fa a livello quotidiano.
Quello che è interessante
è il fatto che l'azione
sta precedendo il discorso.
C'è un discorso pubblico
che, in un certo senso,
è molto più in ritardo
rispetto a quelle che sono
le azioni individuali,
e c'è uno scollo.
Allora, noi - io sono
un'antropologa digitale,
mi occupo di digitale,
credo che il web negli ultimi 20 anni
abbia avuto un impatto
molto forte sui comportamenti.
E abbiamo creato qualcosa
per cercare di mettere insieme
e di facilitare l'azione.
Questa piattaforma la potrete provare
quando avrete il permesso di tirar fuori
i telefonini di nuovo,
si chiama, [è in] beta,
"If You Want To", cioè "se vuoi",
e quello che fa è raccogliere
migliaia di servizi
per aiutare l'azione sostenibile.
C'è dentro di tutto:
da app per condividere viaggi,
a mappe per sapere
se il proprio tetto è orientato
nella direzione giusta,
a modi di trovare, dare via cibo, ecc.
È geolocalizzata:
se guardate ci sono parecchie cose
anche in questa regione:
in Lombardia c'e tantissimo.
Ma quello che è interessante
è che tutta questa base
è stata costituita da una comunità:
la gente continua, giorno dopo giorno
ci propongono delle cose,
ci mettono dentro delle cose.
E quello che stiamo cercando di fare,
in un certo senso,
è dire: non solo agevoliamo l'azione,
non solo permettiamo l'azione
di trovare dei modi di fare,
delle piccole azioni individuali;
ma anche di cercare di dare,
in un certo senso,
uno spazio comune di discorso,
visto che il discorso è assente.
E le reazioni che abbiamo
sono proprio di questo genere:
"Oh, c'è qualcosa, non sono solo.
C'è qualcun altro
che sta facendo qualcosa.
Ma guarda, c'è una cosa divertente
che posso fare".
È questo lo scopo:
cercare di ricongiungere
l'azione al discorso,
e riconoscere che le nostre azioni
stanno andando più velocemente.
Grazie.
(Applausi)